[Music]
seth
is with us in lincoln nebraska hi seth
welcome to the ramsey show
thanks for having me dave our pleasure
how can we help sir
so i recently accepted a promotion
through work
um as decent perry's in my opinion
however i'm trying to decide um
if i if we should purchase a house with
the move
it's about an hour and a half away from
where we live right now and i've been
making the drive
um and it they're paying my mileage up
until the end of next week
um but should i should i purchase a home
should i run a home
were like baby step half
as far as getting our finances and you
have no money
correct well no you should not purchase
a home you're in debt you have no money
yeah go rent man
i think you should move and just rent a
house up there
are you there you're breaking up yep no
i'm here
okay so uh you're are you renting now
yeah we're currently currently running
the house for my father-in-law okay
and so you're going to move to the other
town and rent right
yep i wouldn't be commuting an hour and
a half if that's what you're asking
that's crazy land okay but yeah you
need to move up there and rent and then
you guys need to get you guys need to
lean in now and get your debts paid off
and get yourself an emergency fund built
so you can save a down payment and buy
okay but right now how much less i'm
sorry
right now we're sitting i have about 56
000
in debt between student loans and credit
cards and stuff
how much you own the cars uh
i own my car free and clear both of them
uh yeah we so when we got married
i i came into the marriage with a lot of
that myself so we've kept our finances
separate
okay sound like you had to guess on that
car thing man do you owe anything
on on the other car i don't know
anything on the vehicle we
there's a loan on the wife's truck so so
yeah let me
let me help you with this you're married
all of her debt is your debt all of your
debt is heard at
welcome to marriage
okay so yeah we have we have a loan on
one of the vehicles there we go
okay and so we have
56 we have student loan debt and we have
a truck debt
and uh how much is owed on her truck
uh her trucks just below seven thousand
dollars
okay so do i did i do this correctly so
you
you owe a little over sixty thousand
dollars to become debt free as a family
is that right
yes sir good and what is your household
income now with your new promotion
uh with my new promotion um it
i i don't like counting in bonuses so
it's going to put us where we were
last year without bonuses which would be
72. okay
okay but i count bonuses because they go
into your checking account to use to get
out of debt
so what do you anticipate your bonus to
be reasonably
uh reasonably for if i do what i'm
supposed to do which i plan on obviously
um about another ten thousand so we'd be
sitting about eighty two eighty three
great okay and so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna sit down together
and lay out a budget together and we're
going to set a goal together
of having a debt-free household and then
we're going to build an emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses
those two things should take you about
24 months you should be debt-free and 18
and another six to build your other
but you're on beans and rice during that
time you're not going on vacation
and you're not going out to eat and
you're on a written detailed
plan yeah and when you move seth one of
the one of the things to do on beans and
rice is to make sure that your apartment
i think in that area you should be right
around 20 do not go anything higher than
25
but i want you to look at in between 15
and 20 percent of your take
cheapest possible rent because the
cheaper your rent the faster you're out
of debt the faster you can save up and
buy
yes sir okay all right now we have a
membership
called ramsey plus it puts you through
our class called financial peace
university
it signs you up for the every dollar
premium budgeting app which is the
world's best budgeting app
and uh if if the two of you will work
together and go through that whole thing
i will pay for it for a year for you to
go through it
but you have to promise me both of you
are going to work on this and you're
going to go get yourself straightened
out
because you have an opportunity here to
have a great life in front of you if you
stop
being normal yes sir
will both of you do it if i give it to
you
yes sir okay all right brother you hold
on i'll have kelly pick up and we'll get
you signed up as our gift
so guys the um
just a reminder those of you been
listening a long time know this already
but um
all of the data that we have on people
who build wealth
it almost never occurs
in a household where the spouses are not
working together
one of you dragging the other one along
simply does not is not conducive to
building wealth
as a matter of fact it's quite the
opposite it's going to continue to cause
problems in your relationship it's going
to continue to cause marriage issues
it's going to continue to cause lower
productivity at work because you're
screwed up and fighting all the time
it's going to continue everything until
you can work together to a common goal
that you both agree on and that's
whether you've been married 20 minutes
20 years or 50 years we both
you know we have combined goals we have
combined assets combined
incomes we change our pronouns our
we us not hers and mine
yeah changes everything the probability
of success goes
way up 1 plus 1 does not equal 2 it
equals 42.
you get the synergy of two people
playing off each other pushing each
other holding each other accountable
cheering for each other lifting the
other one up when they're hurting all
the stuff that you do
in marriage when you're working in sync
and in tandem
i love it i always think two is better
than one in my opinion
yeah yeah it it it really does create
that